hello my name is Caitlin Stern and I'm a
numidia fellow at the Santa Fe Institute
on behalf of the Santa Fe Institute I'd
like to thank all of you for coming to
hear this lecture which I think promises
to be very interesting I'd also like to
thank thornbird investment management
for their ongoing and generous
sponsorship of this community lecture
series it's my honor to make it free for
all of us and it's my honor to introduce
our speaker tonight professor Cordelia
fine
professor fine earned her undergraduate
degree in Experimental Psychology from
Oxford University and then she went on
to earn a master's in criminology from
Cambridge University before she earned
her PhD in psychology from University
College London and she is now an
associate professor at the University of
Melbourne in her work professor fine
combines research on how people's
beliefs about gender influence
organizational behavior with a gift for
communicating research to a larger
audience
her book delusions of gender is a
fascinating read that I would recommend
to all of you the major point that I
took away from the book is that while it
may be easy to assume that gender
differences and gender inequality have
their roots in biological differences
the truth is much more complicated and
much more interesting people's behavior
and abilities are influenced by their
social and cultural environments and
complex ways and a large number of
studies have documented these influences
I'm excited to hear professor fine tell
us more about this important topic so
please join me in welcoming her I just
want to begin by saying it's just a
tremendous honor and pleasure to be
speaking here this evening so I'd like
to begin by expressing my thanks to the
Santa Fe Institute for inviting me and
to the sponsors for making it possible
and thank you all for coming this
evening so if you go to your local
bookshop and you go to the gender or the
self-help section you may well find
yourself being reminded that apparently
Mars and women are from Venus and if you
feel like this is a claim that you would
like to see fleshing out a bit more
detail if you just travel a little bit
further along the shelves or maybe
venture to the parenting or the business
section of the shop you'll get some more
information to example you may learn
that men are like waffles and women are
like spaghetti why men want sex and
women want need so I need love why men
don't listen and women can't read maps
why men like straight lines and women
like polka dots you'll learn how women
lead why men don't iron my boys don't
talk why men pull away why men won't
commit and that warren buffett invest
it's like a go and if you're really
lucky you may even find the answer to
that eternal question why can't a woman
be more like a man or of course why
can't a man be more like a woman now the
clear message that emerges from titles
like these is that males and females
have essentially different natures of
psychology's they're so fundamentally
different that these titles imply that
there's a uniquely female way of
investing there's a you Clee uniquely
female way of leading that can be
sharply distinguished from the way that
men lead or the way that men invest over
and over again these titles tell us that
men are like this and women are like
that and this reflects a way of thinking
about differences between the sexes
that's known as gender essentialism so
when we say for example that boys will
be boys what we mean is that there's
some kind of underlying male essence
that's shared by almost all men and boys
that regardless of cultural cultural
background or historical period or place
or context that cleanly distinguishes
distinguishes them from females sex
differences of youth is natural fixed
the same everywhere and at all times
with a sharp boundary between the sexes
and if the sexes are fundamentally
different in this way then surely their
brains are - as you can see here
neuroscience has revealed that the
female brain is made of tangled
telephone cord and the male brain
is made of duct tape
and again there's no shortage of popular
books elaborating on the differences
between male and female brains and the
implications for our different natures
so for example in one of John Grey's
more recent books he writes that the
first step in understanding and
accepting our differences is to
recognize that men and women are
actually hardwired to be different in
this complementary set of books it's a
baby girl and it's a baby boy the author
Michael Gurion tells parents that
researchers have literally seen what
we've always known there are fundamental
German differences and they start in a
very structure of the human brain in
this book geared towards business
leaders the author writes that the
differences between men's and women's
brains explain the considerable
differences and how they operate in the
workplace how they lead communicate act
react problem-solve
make decisions and work together and
target again towards that business
audience and in a recent book by barbara
anise and John Gray respectfully
reviewed and The Economist and Forbes
they write that many differences are
hardwired into the brain structures of
males and females and affect the way
each gender processes information
rationalizes situations communicates
makes decisions nor is it only non
scientists making these kinds of claims
the neuropsychiatrist learn Bruce Dean
describes the female brain as a
high-performance emotion machine geared
to tracking a moment-by-moment the
nonverbal signals of the innermost
feelings of others while the male brain
by contrast is a lean mean
problem-solving machine faced with a
personal problem a manual uses
analytical brain structures not as
emotional ones to find a solution and
this very long-held dichotomy between
Wimmers women as feelers and men as
thinkers is described in a more formal
way by the Cambridge psychologist Sloane
Baron Cohen who writes the female brain
is predominately hardwired for empathy
the male brain is predominately
hardwired for understanding and building
systems and these different talents and
interests of the female and male brain
who is excelling at caring for others is
excelling at understanding it
manipulating the world are proposed by
Baron Cohen and many others to explain
the continuing sex segregation in the
workplace which still sees men
predominating in
the more prestigious and well-paid
occupations and roles and last year an
article was published in the prestigious
journal Proceedings of the National
Academy of Sciences that according to
the press release reported striking
differences between men and women's
brains that helps explain different
cognitive strengths in men and women and
lends credence to some commonly held
beliefs about their behavior one of the
researchers went on to say for instance
men are more likely better on average
men are more likely better at learning
and performing a single task at hand
like cycling or navigating directions
presumably they're not doing both at
once whereas women have superior memory
and social cognition skills making them
more equipped for multitasking and
creating solutions that work for a group
and these themes continued in the global
headlines because this this science
article had a huge impact in the news
media so some of the headlines focused
on this theme of the mail Fiat female
brains being very differently wired so
we had why men and women's brains work
differently it's all about the wiring
men's women's brains wired differently
and the National posts are a little bit
technical men's brains go back to front
women's go side to side
other other headlines focused on the
implication that these different this
different brain wiring also has
important implications for psychology so
for example we had yes each sex really
is from a different planet brain scans
may support Venus Mars divided between
the sexes and this New Zealand Herald
obviously thought that that sort of
different planets metaphor was a bit
overblown and hoped so they decided to
merely describe men and women as being
wired like different species some
headlines specified some examples and
ways in which men and women are
different so we had wine men can't
explain women why men and women are
poles apart differences in the way the
brains of men and women are wired helps
to explain why men are better at
navigating and while women can multitask
and my favorite women crack at parking
official
but it was this headline from Forbes
that really got to the nub of the social
implications of supposedly of the
findings is Equal Opportunity threatened
by new findings that female and male
brains are different now this is a
question we've been asking for a very
long time for as long as there has been
brain science there have been claims
that sex differences in the brain
explain why men and women are very
different and therefore it's suited to
different roles in society and with
hindsight these arguments never look
very pretty but actually looking back to
the mistakes of the past offers some
useful lessons that we can apply to the
present for example back in the late
19th century the respected biologist
Audra - argued that seeing that the
average brain weight of women is about 5
ounces less than that of men on merely
anatomical grounds we should be prepared
to expect a market inferiority of
intellect in the former he then went on
to say moreover as the general physique
of women is less robust than that of men
and therefore less able to sustain
fatigue of serious or prolonged brain
action we should also on physiological
grounds be prepared to entertain a
similar anticipation
apparently runners had never met a
muscular idiot or a weedy intellectual
or consider this opinion piece in The
New York Times from 1915 in which the
neurologists looked at how neuroscience
could illuminate the question of women's
suffrage speaking of the woman's nervous
system and the differences between men's
and women's he said the upper half of
the spinal cord is smaller the lower
half which controls the pelvis and limbs
is much larger now he was admirably
circumspect about the implications of
this I do not say that these structural
differences will prevent a woman from
voting but they
but they will prevent her from ever
becoming a man and they point the way to
the fact that women's efficiency lies in
a special field I think the word pelvis
may be a clue here as to what that is
and not that of political initiative or
of judicial authority in a community's
organization now this may be a good
point to say that there are effects of
biological sex on the brain we do not
have an asexual brain and studying and
understanding how sex linked genes and
hormones can influence brain development
and function is likely to be very
important for understanding for example
why it is that for many pathologies of
brain and mind one sex is more
vulnerable than the other my thesis is
not that there are no sex differences in
the brain or that these differences
should not be studied but there are two
lessons here that we can learn from the
historical examples that I've just
described and the first is that we
should be very careful about the
assumptions that we make about
behavioral differences between the sexes
and the second
relatedly is that we should be very
careful about the sumption as we make
about how sex differences in the brain
related to behavioral differences george
Romanus was confident that women were
inherently intellectually inferior to
men dr. Charles Donna was skeptical that
they could be competent participants in
the political process and this as we saw
led them astray when it came to
interpreting what brain differences
meant so smaller brain was assumed to
mean an intellectually inferior brain a
hypothesis that was extremely popular in
the Victorian era and a certain spiral
core characteristic was speculated to be
a sign of vulnerability to our
excitement in the voting booth
now obviously neuroscience and social
attitudes have progressed enormous Lee
since these speculations were made but
is it possible that we're still
exaggerating or somehow misperceiving
differences between the sexes and their
behavior and that this continues to
misdirect human neuroscience when we
think in a gender essentialist way of
women as being universally timelessly an
immutable 'i like this and men like that
it intuitively makes sense to think that
there's a female brain that creates that
distinctive feminine mind or essence and
a male brain that creates that
distinctive masculine mind or essence
and this in turn
is connecting sex differences in the
brain seem a relatively simple task it
seems that with our powerful and
sophisticated your imaging technologies
we should surely be able by comparing
the brains of men and women extract our
extract out the noise of individual
variability and find the particular
female brain characteristic associated
with feminine ways of thinking feeling
and behaving and the particular male
brain characteristics associated with
essential or masculine traits and
implicitly or explicitly this is what
many human neuroimaging studies are sex
differences seem to try to do and one
example of this which I'll come back to
later
is that Proceedings of National Academy
of Sciences paper and we'll come back to
that as an example but although there
are sex differences in the brain and
there are sex differences in behavior
scientific understanding of both have
overthrow overthrowing this simple model
and so in this main part of my talk I'm
going to run quickly through three ways
in which the scientific data undermine
an essentialist understanding of sex
differences and behavior in three ways
in which scientific understanding
undermines the notion of timeless
universal fixed male brains and female
brains that underlie these male and
female essences and I'll start with sex
differences in behavior and in
particular three important features of
what we might describe as the shape of
gender characteristics and the first is
overlap so although we talk about
feminine traits and masculine traits
this is just a convenient shorthand
because in many cases although males on
average as a group may sure show more
for example of a particular trait many
individual males will nonetheless be
more feminine so to speak than the
typical female and vice-versa and a
useful statistic for quantifying this
overlap is the effect size this is the
difference in mean between two groups
divided by the standard deviation but to
show it to you visually which is a bit
more sort of readily graspable this
shows an effect size of 1.4 which is
more or less the effect size for sex
differences in height so with an effect
size of 1.4 about half of the female and
male distributions overlap meaning about
half of every of all men could be
matched with a woman of a similar size
and the probability of randomly choosing
and
who's taller than a randomly chosen
woman is about 84% so how does this
compare with some of the quintessential
gendered psychological traits well this
is but more or less the largest sex
difference in a cognitive trait which is
a rounded up effect size for mental
rotation which is a component of spatial
processing and you can see that it's
considerably smaller than the effect
size for height now more than
three-quarters of men could be matched
with an equally able woman and the
probability of randomly chosen men being
superior than a randomly chosen woman is
about two times over three so that's
certainly a difference but it's far from
absolute there's a lot of variability
now here's a visualization of the effect
size for attender mindedness so women on
average report being more tender minded
but about 38% of men will be more tender
minded than the average woman and 88% of
women could be matched with a man who
reported themselves as being equally
tender minded and in fact this kind of
overlap
considerable overlap is a rule rather
than the exception when it comes to the
majority of gendered character
psychological characteristics so very
well known review in 2005 which reviewed
46 statistical reviews or meta-analyses
which covered a range of cognitive
social personality and well-being
well-being variables that yielded 124
effect sizes found that 30% of them were
in the very small range and that top
graph there shows you what that looks
like visually
48% was small and 15% were medium so
while there are exceptions the overall
prints the overlap principle means that
for the majority of psychological
characteristics a person sex is not
going to be particularly accurate
predictor of whether they're masculine
or feminine on a particular gender trait
and what that means that if you're a
crew ting group of women and a group of
men - and you're imaging study it's
highly unlikely that your women's scores
will all fall neatly on the sort of
feminine side of the mean and your men
on the masculine side of the mean
instead they're both going to be
distributed distributed on both sides of
the mean a second important feature of
gendered behavior is its contingency so
whenever you make a statement like men
and war this or women
with that it always needs to be
qualified with information well which
men are you referring to in which kind
of situation in which context so for
example here are three claims that we
often hear main differences between the
sexes a cognitive empathy mathematics
anxiety and neuroticism and you find
that they all have contingency in them
so for example bill arcus and colleagues
have found that the claim that women are
better at cognitive empathy that is
working out what somebody's thinking or
feeling it's only the case when women
are subtly reminded of their supposed
superiority otherwise perhaps
surprisingly men are equally good in
terms of mathematics data for a millions
of Americans shows that the accuracy of
the claim that males are veteran
mathematics or indeed more highly
represented in that right-hand tale of
extreme mobility depends on ethnicity
and sometimes it's the case that females
have a slight advantage and when it
comes to anxiety neuroticism typically
women do report more but not in all
countries for example not in Japan or
among black South Africans and although
there are sex differences in self-esteem
with white Americans having less women
having lower self-esteem this is not the
case for black Americans on average in
short the contingent contingency
principle means that you can't report
sex differences in a particular
population or a particular context and
then very confidently generalize to
other populations or other contexts you
may find it very robustly reliably in
one population or one situation but that
doesn't mean you can assume it's
universal and this means that any brain
differences associated with behavioral
differences will be contingent - and the
third feature of gendered
characteristics is what's been called
mosaicism or what we might call the
gender pick a mix so if you take a look
at these quotations all of them came
from were said by an entrepreneur and
you can see that two are kind of
expressing stereotypically feminine
beliefs or values and two
stereotypically masculine so we have it
was a great relief to me that my partner
handed all the negotiations finance
board the pants off me most importantly
I wanted to have a home life which we've
never had before
and I wanted to be able to spend more
time with the children then on the other
side we have being me I was determined
to do things differently I travel on the
road I slept sometimes alone I slept
wherever I could and took terrific risks
and as a child I had the monopoly on
American comics and bubblegum and I knew
how to use it had the leverage in power
to swap my precious commodities for
whole collections of cigarette cards and
movie albums now if I have to ask you
you know who where do you think the
entrepreneur who said these things you
know which ones you think was said by a
female entrepreneur and which by a male
entrepreneur you're probably and assume
that I'm trying to trick you and that
the you know these sort of counter
stereotypical examples but actually the
point here is that these quotations all
came from the same person and that was a
neat erotic founder of the body shop and
this is an example used by cursor and
ARB in other words the point here is
that Roddick was a mix of masculine and
feminine quality she had both and I
would guess that most of you if not all
of you here tonight if you were to
reflect on your own qualities for a
moment would probably conclude that you
too are also a mix of stereotypically
masculine and feminine skills attitudes
interests and so on and this is
important because for a long time it was
assumed that a person's gender could be
located somewhere on a sort of single
dimension that ran from masculinity to
femininity then it was proposed that
there are two dimensions masculinity and
femininity but it's coming but creasing
Lee clear that even this two-dimensional
model is too simple that masculine
characteristics are only very weakly
correlated with each other if at all
meaning that you know knowing that
someone has one particular masculine
trait doesn't tell you very much about
whether they have another masculine
trait and the same for feminine
characteristics in other words gender is
multi-dimensional so if the television
you're a scientist and definite role
puts it it means that individuals
possess a complicated array of masculine
and feminine characteristics that cannot
be captured by a uni-dimensional or by
dimensional model and this raises an
interesting question if each or most of
us is made up of a complex array of
masculine and feminine characteristics
and we assume as
to make sense that that there's a neural
basis to these masculine and feminine
characteristics how do we decide you
know which woman and which man or which
particular sort of idiosyncratic array
of the agenda traits would sort of
represent the person who had a female
brain or a male brain you could choose
two different women in the audience and
they have very different mix of
masculine and feminine traits which one
of them if any has a female brain so we
can start to see how the overlap the
contingency and the mosaicism of gender
creates difficulty for the idea the
traditional model of sex differences
over on the right here so for example
when we think of risk-taking as an
essential masculine characteristics
characteristic which we often do we kind
of think of risk-taking as being
something that that males do for
evolutionary reasons as a sort of
inherent stable fundamental
characteristic of being a man this
pushes us towards explanations in terms
of a single predominant cause that
creates discontinuity between two groups
in other words biological sex that
creates some kind of sex difference in
the brain that we might be able to
identify if we were to compare the
brains of men and women but what happens
when we replace the essentialist
generalization that men are more
risk-taking with a more accurate picture
shown by behavioral research this is
shown that of course females take risks
to this considerable overlap in
risk-taking behavior whether or not sex
differences exists can depend on the
domain of risk-taking on the context on
the way the task is framed and also
importantly on the cultural background
of the men and women involved and it's
also the case that someone who takes
risks in one kind of domain like
financial risks isn't necessarily
someone likely to take risks in another
area like physical or social risks so it
has a mosaic structure so when we say
instead more accurately not males are
more risk-taking but some males of some
cultural backgrounds from some
populations are more risk-taking in some
domains in some context but not others
than our son but nor all women
it no longer seemed so likely that we'll
be able to compare the brains of women
and men and from average differences
between the groups identify the neural
basis of Greater male risk-taking and
this brings us to three important
features of sex differences in the brain
so until quite recently the dominant
scientific model of sexual
differentiation differentiation of the
brain and soon assumed a relatively
simple serial developmental pathway that
traveled from male or female genes to
male or female gonads to male or female
sex hormones and different proportions
to a male or female brain circuitry but
as Margaret McCarthy and Arthur Arnold
recently explained in nurtured nature
neuroscience new evidence has been
overturning this old model now neither
geneticist nor in your endocrinologist
but to draw out the principles from this
emerging research in this area as best
as I can and this is based on animal
research this old simple serial model is
being replaced with one in which many
different genetic hormonal epigenetic
and environmental factors all act and
interact together in parallel and just
to make things even more complicated the
dynamic of that interaction can be
different in different locations of the
brain and one important consequence of
this complexity is that what emerges is
not a discrete male circuit versus a
discrete female circuit but a mosaic of
relative maleness and femaleness in the
brain I just want to clarify that image
on the right that's I did that in
PowerPoint it's not actually the brain
just in case there was any confusion
there and as definitely do all this
point to that this lack of internal
consistency when it comes to these sort
of more male typical or female
characteristics these arrays that the
individuals have is that sex influences
don't add up to create brains that we
could put neatly into female brain and
male brain categories and nor do they
can they be located on a maleness to
femaleness continuum now second
important principle to have emerged from
neuro scientific research is the insight
that these very complex sex differences
or sex effects in the brain
necessarily add up and up and up to
create more and more difference in
behavior so counter-intuitively
one sex effect may compensate for
another and a really nice example of
this comes from songbirds so in some
songbirds there is a sex difference in
the size of a particular region of the
brain which can think of the as a song
control center and that actually is
related to singing behavior so there's
that link has been made between the sex
difference in the brain and the sex
difference in the behavior with a male
singing more than the females but in the
African first weaverbird you still have
that sex difference in the brain it's
about one and a half times larger in the
male birds but actually males and
females sing similar songs they sing in
unison so how how does that happen well
the answer seems to be at a sex
difference in gene expression which
takes place at a much higher level in
the females in the relevant genes in a
relevant area than in males and so what
you have here is you've got two sex
differences in the brain but they're
cancelling each other out the sex
difference in gene expression cancels
out the sex difference in brain size to
create similarity of behavior now this
isn't to say that all sex differences in
the brain cancel each other out but it
does mean that we can't assume that any
sex difference in the brain serves to
create the behavioral difference and it
also means that as we learn more and
more generally from animal research
applause from humor search human
research about sex differences in the
brain it doesn't mean that we're finding
more and more evidence of more and more
difference in the psychologies of males
and females and as a last point about
brain the brain the principle of
experience-dependent brain plasticity is
now well-established we're all very
familiar now with the concept of brain
plasticity and what feminist scientists
have been pointing out for a long time
is that social phenomenon of gender as a
social category linked to difference and
inequality means that a person's sex
what sex you happen to be born will
systematically influence this like
logical the social or the material the
physical experiences that you have and
this means of course that when you
compare the brains of men and women who
come into the lab that means that what
you're looking at when you look at the
brain are not the pure effects of
biological sex
as many have pointed out what you're
actually looking at is sex entangled
with gender that gender is literally
incorporated so we're now a very long
way from this simple traditional
essentialist model so instead of male
brains and female brains we have
idiosyncratic arrays of male typical and
female typical brain characteristics
some of these features and differences
may serve to create the havel similarity
rather than different so different
neural roots to the same behavioral ends
and they're entangled with a lifetime of
gendered experiences rather than being
pure manifestations of biological sex
meanwhile the gendered behavior that you
might be trying to link brain
differences to is a very messy and
moving target it's overlapping it's
contingent and its mosaic so the true
complexity of this situation should make
it less surprising that even an animal
research where both environments and
experimentation can be more tightly
controlled it's been surprisingly
different difficult to link sex
differences in the brain to sex
differences in behavior as to
endocrinologist summarized at few years
ago hundreds of sex differences have
been found in the central nervous system
but only a handful can be clearly linked
to sex differences in behavior the best
examples are found in the spinal cord in
other words the higher up you get in
terms of behavior and harder it gets we
do not know the functional consequences
of most of the others so now we can
return to the PNAS paper with all this
under our belts so very briefly what
this study found they modelled the brain
connectivity of nearly a thousand young
people and the reported greater within
hemispheric connectivity in males and
greater between hemispheric connectivity
in females and to understand how we get
from this finding to the press release
headlines and the news headlines that we
saw we need to take a look at the
influence of the traditional
essentialist model on both research
design and interpretation so first of
all the sex differences in brain
connectivity that they found were
differences of degree not of
find their quantitative not qualitative
so one point is that the the research
has really emphasized the connectivity
differences that were significantly
different between the sexes leaving it
unclear how many connectivity patterns
were not were similar between the sexes
and an independent calculation of the
effect size found that even number the
largest connectivity difference that was
an effect size of about 0.4 eight which
I've sort of Illustrated there so that
means that there have been plenty of men
in the sample who even for this
connectivity pattern but the largest
difference would have had a sort of more
female
style of connectivity than the typical
female and yet despite this similarity
the differences were described as being
fundamental differences and visually
they're presented as very dichotomous
the researchers also had access to data
from a previous study that they did with
a much larger sample of participants
from which their brain scanning
participants were drawn and these
reported sex differences in an arranged
battery of psychological tasks good
executive control memory reasoning
spatial processing sensory motor skills
and social cognition and these actually
show a considerable overlap between the
sexes so they had 26:26 effect sizes
here eleven of those were in the zeros
and non significant males and females
identical 2.1 range and so at that point
one is illustrated in that top graph
here the largest effect size was 0.33 so
that's illustrated in the graph below
and everything else was somewhere in
between there so you can see there was
actually a lot of psychological
similarity between the sexes on this
battery yet these differences in
behavior were described as pronounced
and as reflecting behavioral
complementarity males are like this
females are like that there was no
assessment of mosaicism in behavioral
traits or brain connectivity differences
so we don't know whether men and women
or males and females tended to be
consistently feminine and masculine
either in their behavioral profiles or
in their brain connectivity patterns and
this makes a difference to how plausible
it is
that an average brain connectivity
pattern can be is likely to be linked
with in some way to an average masculine
and feminine behavioral profile and the
researchers paid no attention either
empirically or conceptually to the
possible role of gendered experiences
and the development of either behavioral
skills or brain connectivity patterns so
for example they didn't assess gendered
experiences like hobbies or subjects
studied at school or in higher education
or participation in sporting activities
and this by the way actually misses an
opportunity to investigate whether these
kinds of gendered experiences might
influence brain development and/or
enhance the kinds of skills that are
valuable and important for everyone
have another important possibility that
the author's didn't consider is that
their results could have had more to do
with brain size than to do with sex so
George Romanus was right male brains are
on average larger than females back in
his time they used to refer to that as
the missing five answers of female brain
we don't describe it that way anymore
but the thing is is that a larger brain
is not the same as a smaller brain
simply scaled up larger brains create
different sorts of engineering problems
and so in order to minimize energy need
demands wiring costs and communication
times there may be good physical reasons
for different arrangements in
differently sized brains and so the
results may reflect the different wiring
solutions of larger versus smaller
brains different patterns of brain
connectivity in other words may
compensate for brain size differences in
effect a subsequent study published
about a year later found that
connectivity differences between the
sexes were actually driven by brain size
rather than sex so for example when
groups were selected that were matched
on brain size there was no effect of sex
on connectivity pattern so we can see
that there's there are many reasons not
to simply assume that sex differences
found in brain connectivity explain
behavioral sex differences or of course
that in the brain means hardwired or
untouched by experience but if you're
thinking about the results in a kind of
dichotomous men are from Mars Women are
from Venus Way male brains are like this
female brains are like that males behave
like this females behave like that you
overlook the overlap the contingency the
possible mosaicism the principle of
compensation of entanglement then it
seems much more plausible to connect the
two and you can see that the researchers
are thinking in this way they say these
match shows a stark difference and
complementarity in the architecture of
the human brain that helps provide a
potential neural basis as to why men
excel at certain tasks and women others
and so plausible does it seem to them
that these two these these behavioral
differences are connected that they
speculate that male brains are
structured to facilitate connectivity
between between perception and
coordinated action whereas female brains
are designed to facilitate communication
between analytical and intuitive
processing modes and of course we saw
the further speculations in the press
relief press release but importantly the
researchers didn't actually test for
correlations between brain connectivity
pattern and psychological profile now
shortly before this study hit the news I
was actually sent the article by a u.s.
journalist who asked me to comment on it
I didn't see the press release that that
happens but I read the article and after
reading it this is what I wrote to her I
said ironically even though the research
from this group provides strong evidence
for behavioral similarities between the
sexes provides no evidence that any
modest behavioral sex differences are
associated with neurological ones and
offers no information about the
developmental origins of either we can
probably anticipate this article will
soon be drawn on by popular commentators
as evidence that hardwired sex
differences explain why men are from
Mars and women are from Venus and as
we've seen this is exactly what happened
this was the front page of the UK
newspaper The Independent scientists
discover the difference between male and
female brains and I don't know if you
can read that subheading there but it
says study reveals variation in hard
wiring which may explain the skills gap
between women and men and notice how all
the key features of essentialist
thinking are here we've got male brains
and female brains we've got a gap rather
than overlap in skills the researchers
have identified the brain difference
between the sexes the implication being
that this is a difference that is
timeless fixed Universal and this
hard-wired difference has profound
behavioral consequences that may help
explain the sexual status quo now if you
feel that front page headlines like this
aren't very helpful for the cause of
Greater sex equality and you're probably
right
there was actually a content analysis
was done of the news and social media
reactions to this particular study
because it was did receive an unusual
amount of attention I have to say and
this is how they summarized their
findings of its effects in both
scientific and popular contexts
traditional gender stereotypes were
projected onto the novel scientific
information which was harnessed to
demonstrate the factual truth and
normative legitimacy of these beliefs
this content often resembled a form of
benevolent sexism in which praise of
women's social-emotional skills
compensated for the relegation from more
esteemed tre domains such as rationality
and productivity and the authors argue
that the neuroscience of sex difference
does not merely reflect but can actively
shape the gender norms of a contemporary
society and this is consistent with what
research has shown about the effects of
gender essentialist thinking which is
associated among other things with
increased endorsement of gender
stereotypes and greater acceptance of
the sexual status quo and so some
colleagues and I decided that it was
time for a small intervention so these
are my wonderful colleagues Jena Ripon
Annalise Kaiser and Rebecca Jordan young
and what we wanted to do was write a
paper that provided a useful overview of
these key principles that I've just been
briefly describing to you that have
emerged out of decades of gender
scholarship and recent neuroscience and
make recommendations as to how these
principles can be incorporated into
human neuroimaging design and
interpretation and I hope was not just
that these this article be useful for
researchers themselves as they were sort
of designing interpreting their
experiments but also to journal editors
and reviewers who of course the
gatekeepers for the quality of
scientific publications and also to
science communicators to provide them
with the critical lens with which to
view neuroscientific research in this
area and I just want to go through a few
aspects of some of the things that we
suggested so here we have human your
imaging research as it's
they often conducted so you have your
sample that's divided on the basis of
biological sex and then you have some
kind of experiment like brain activity
during this risk-taking for example and
then you get some kind of result that
maybe implicitly or explicitly regarded
as the neural sex difference in
risk-taking and that tends to be the end
of the research story so how do we said
do we do research of this kind that's
informed by gender scholarship well one
thing I have time touched on here is
that's a bit more complicated and we
might assume but one important point
that we made is that researchers
explicitly take account of what is
usually invisible because we're so
blinded by sex which is that no
individual who has come to a brain
scanning lab has been freshly unwrapped
from their mailbox or their female box
but they come to you with a lifetime of
gender socialization experiences and
whenever you compare men and women those
gender gender socialization experiences
are captured and that parent comparison
and can't really be retrospectively
disentangled and so we've suggested is
that first of all researchers sort of be
more explicitly aware of this and then
perhaps even try to quantify it in some
way our next point relates to sort of
various modeling and technical aspects
of the experiment that are based on
implicit assumptions about the shape of
the phenomenon and measurement and
hypotheses and analysis of data and so
on but I think one interesting thing
here is to bear in mind that when you do
an experiment you're doing an experiment
in a particular social and cultural
context and in fact the results of your
experiment may even through
popularization become part of gender
socialization and then the experimental
project itself becomes entangled with
the very phenomenon of interest and this
point leads finally to the recognition
there any result that you get from a
single neuroimaging study is actually
not the result but it's just a snapshot
of a particular population in a
particular moment of time in a
particular context rather than something
that can be assumed to be a static
general universe Eliza below manam and
when you stop there
just take that result and stop there
you're guaranteed not to produce any
data that can challenge the idea of
fixed universal male versus female
neural essences but from a research
model informed by gender scouts the
scholarship this isn't the end of the
research process this is actually just
the beginning of the research story and
you move from that initial result to
test whether and how findings are
contingent contingent on the population
on the experience or a context you start
to probe the result further and this we
predict this kind of neuroscience would
lead to very different kinds of
newspaper headlines as I hope have
managed to convey when it comes to
gender research the relations between
science and society are two-way and
although what I've outlined this evening
is sort of more example of the negative
side of that it can certainly work to
positive effect as well it was our hope
that through research informed by key
principles from gender scholarship
researchers have some really exciting
and important opportunities to challenge
cultural assumptions about the relations
between sex gender and the brain but in
the meantime until that happens the
simpler take-home message that I have
for you is this next time you read a
book or a news article that claiming to
show that nourish neuroscience has shown
that men and women are fundamentally
different you'll know that it hasn't
shown what isn't thank you
you have the gentleman there okay um I
think in terms of this school failure
it's important to always think about
well which which boys are we talking
about because it may be certain pockets
of boys for whom sure yeah yeah I think
probably you probably need us someone
else to answer that question more
adequately but I suppose you could point
to the questions like well if they're in
somewhere where the sort of the
traditionally the the kinds of
employment that that boys would be
growing into and that has been shot to
pieces for economic reasons that there
may be sort of things going on or that
level but in terms of the increased
vulnerability of boys particularly you
know to sort of develop mental disorders
and so on and so forth I think that
comes back to this key point to do with
not saying you know it's we're not
saying that the the brains of boys and
girls are identical and there may be
some aspects of different ways that male
and female brains sorry the brains of
men males and females function that that
increases vulnerability to particular
types of psychopathology of brain or
mind but it's important not to
extrapolate from that sort of in a very
general way so it's just to give one
example we all know that males are more
vulnerable to you know the autism
spectrum disorder one aspect of which
can be a difficulty to work out what
other people are thinking and feeling
but when you actually look in in the
sort of general population if you ask
many women how good they are at knowing
you know when someone's feeling bored or
some wants to enter a conversation women
are you know women are superior to men
but when you actually test them on this
ability in a sort of rigorous way by
filming people by getting each
interactive to say what they're thinking
and feeling at a particular time then
asking the other person okay what do you
think this person was thinking and
feeling and then totting up the scores
as I mentioned you actually find that
men are just as capable of that as women
it's an important point to say yes we
can have these sort of vulnerabilities
that come probably comes from sort of
brain characteristics that differ
between the sexes but we shouldn't sort
of say well what all boys are like this
or all men are like this yes I think you
had your hand up before so I'll go to
you I think in my research I've really
focused predominantly I've been
interested in the kinds of claims around
why it is that you see occupational
inequality so that's really been my
focus on those kinds of characteristics
rather than things around gender
identity for example I think what we're
seeing more and more of both in the
science and in societies this kind of
unraveling of the kind of tight hold
that we think by a resume that
biological sex has on on that this
process of development but beyond that
since it's not my area I can't I can't
really say much more than that yep
oh I think the question is why is it
that we continue to see both scientific
research of this kind and these kinds of
headlight headlines that that sort of
perpetuate these stereotypes and and
sort of naturalized the status quo I
think there probably a number of factors
so one very obvious one is that a sort
of headline a news headline that says
you know men and women are a radically
different
it's more exciting than for example the
results of a meta-analysis that says
look many women are actually kind of
similar though it's interesting question
you know why why that would that would
be more interesting I think in this
particular instance I think the
scientists themselves played a very
large role in kind of pre popularizing
their findings and and I would like to
say that you know obviously there are
many scientists who would would present
their findings in a more responsible way
and the neuroscience community itself
was very good at sort of immediately
pointing out some of the problems with
this but there are some data showing
that that yes there's kind of
essentialist
thinking that this kind of research
supports people turn to it when their
motive to justify the system is
activated so under the particular kinds
of conditions people can sort of want to
cling on to the status quo more firmly
and it's been found that people are sort
of find this kind of sign
and its conclusions more appealing and
more convincing when they're in that
kind of state so there's definitely a
very important relationship between
gender essentialism and the sort of
justification of the status quo and
that's why that's why I sort of feel
it's really important to get this the
science right yes what these are these
are very difficult things and I think so
is there it is I think just put it less
politely than the questionnaire did yeah
can you do anything useful with this
information in particular how can you
stop girls sort of moving out of
interest in things like chess or with
computer computer science or
traditionally masculine areas I guess
there are a few things here and actually
one of them does lead back to this
question of gender essentialism so some
of you may have heard of a phenomenon
called stereotype threat whereby when
people are performing securing its women
in mathematics they're performing in a
domain where they sort of traditionally
perceived or stereotype to be inferior
inferior in their sort of performing
under this threat of confirming that
stereotype so they're kind of doing it
for the whole sex and if they screw up
then you know that it seems like they'll
have shown the s women
can't do maths and one really
interesting study found that if you
present the same stereotype about women
and maths but presented as result of
experience or factors rather than
genetic factors which people sort of
assumed to be sort of immutable and
fixed then you actually don't see the
stereotype a threat even though you're
still referring to that same different
sex difference in mathematical ability
so it may be something that the gender
essentialism really is what give that
gives these stereotypes their kick and
stereotype threat has been also a linked
to sort of a reduction in interest as
well so not just performance but you
know how much women or girls are
interested in sort of going into
traditionally masculine domains and so
again I think this is why this is really
key because if you feel that sort of
it's not being for you is sort of a
really core aspect of yourself then I
think that's not going to be very
helpful in terms of trying to break down
those barriers but I think more
generally the more we see males and
females is just being very different and
I think I said a contemporary childhood
culture with its penka fication is
really emphasizing that in actually
surprisingly unprecedented way then
you're kind of encouraging as
developmental psychologists I think
including one in this room have shown
that you're when you when you make sort
of social categories very salient you
increase that kind of in-group Pride and
Prejudice making it harder to kind of
cross those across those boundaries so I
said think in general the less we're
sort of emphasizing difference in this
sort of minimize metaphor Myers went
from venous dialogue it's sort of you
help in that small way and it has of
course has to be done in myriad ways to
maybe break down that kind of or this is
for you and this is for you kind of
mentality I so how to choose I'll go to
this side of the room again yeah
well yeah you have to have sorry the
question was why focus on the
neurobiology rather than evolutionary
biology for example where you might
similarly find biases I suppose one
reason was just how I ended up in this
area which was from reading well our
chair was involved in a project on
neuroethics which was looking at what
are some of the ethical or philosophical
implications that are arising out of the
new and your imaging technologies and at
the same time I was reading parenting
books I've got two children I read a lot
of parenting books after go away mommy's
reading had to be a better parent and
and it was one of these books that was
talking about sex differences in the
brain and the implications for parenting
that got me really interested in the
topic and and since I also did my PhD
that Institute of cognitive neuroscience
not so initially sparked my interest
because they were actually talking about
a part of the brain that I studied in my
PhD I thought that's interesting I
didn't know that and then I went to the
look at the research study that have
being cited and it really just started
from there
but I agree it's and actually I've
started to look at they sort of you know
obviously evolutionary psychology has
had its critics in the past and of
course we can place all of this in that
larger picture of all why would we
expect men and women to be fundamentally
different which you know the old story
it all goes back to the small sperm and
that big fat expensive egg and as you
rightly point out there are there are
all sorts of troubles with that and
evolutionary biology has really sort of
transformed over the decades and evil
issue psychology doesn't always seem to
have caught up but I think that's the
sort of topic for another lecture yeah
right there at the back and that
yeah there's the yeah and that some that
sort of been the starting premise of
sorry yeah sorry the question was has
there been any studies looking at sexual
orientation the sort of working
hypothesis being that you would have the
sort of the brain of the other sex
yes so I again I sexual orientation is
not something I know something about but
Rebecca Jordan young who's the author of
a wonderful book called brainstorm has
has looked at this kind of how these
assumptions that you kind of get
everything in a package and they all go
together but with problem with it the
research as she shows is that the way
that masculinity and femininity have
been are being defined in these studies
are actually changing from study to
study so that what looks like a coherent
picture from the outside once you start
to look more closely is actually
internally inconsistent but again that's
not really my area so it's not not
something I can speak on with any
authority I think we have to stop yet
one more question so over the hand up
there yep perceived sex differences
by age and across different cultures
sorry do you mean that people perceive
the differences to be different yep yep
if I've understood correctly scissors to
do with the degree to which so some sex
differences that you may see in some
places you might not see and others that
risk taking is a really nice example of
that so a huge amount of research and
financial risk taking has used as is
often the case in psychology it's used
of North American or European college
students and that tends to find that
males like on these sort of lottery
tasks will take riskier options than
females one interesting thing is that
actually when you raise the stakes to
make them really significant you lose
that sex difference so it's kind of
suggests that maybe what's going on in
these lower stakes instance this is a
sort of reputational things unit of
identity is a risk taker that sort of
play a greater role in those low stakes
but once you've actually got you know
serious money to lose then you just
start to sort of behave in more similar
ways but really interestingly people who
have gone sort of outside the university
campuses for example to compare
matrilineal and patriarchal societies
have found a sort of flipping over so
actually you get the sort of Greater
male risk-taking in the patriarchal
cultures but greater female or similar
risk female risk-taking in the
matrilineal cultures so that's a you
know a really nice example of the
contingency of those what we see if this
is sort of coming back to the question
of our evolutionary biology this sort of
really essential masculine trait I think
I have to stop now thank you for the
question